reven white is a quarterback and he had
an opportunity to go to the power 5
schools Arizona State Oregon State
Tennessee Utah Washington State for star
quarterback his brother plays
quarterback at Arizona State and all of
a sudden decides he's going to Princeton
now that's not the norm and I thought
good for him because you're looking at
not a four-year window here of what your
life is going to be about it's going to
be the next 40 years and it doesn't mean
you still can't go to the NFL because
once you get to the combine then
everybody gets a chance to see you so
brevin white joining us on vacation from
cancun revin congratulations on the
decision how difficult was this
thanks mr. Patrick and it was a very
hard decision ultimately taking you know
school that you know I'd be attending
for you know the next four years of my
my life and it was hard it was hard to
kind of narrow it down a pasta you know
scholarship opportunities that I could
go to and have school paid for and you
know playing in front of big crowds and
you know kind of all those tell us about
it but it's it's definitely a life
decision and it's you know it's a
decision that's going to impact you
pretty much the rest of your life and
there are a lot of factors that play
into you know making a college decision
and it's more of you know it's bigger
than just the football and just the
academic situations bigger than just
going to kind of the best University for
those reasons I focus more on you know
the environment I see myself living
there and kind of all the extra details
about it so there's a lot of factors
that I kind of went through you know
with my mental process through this
whole thing and ultimately you know came
to the conclusion that Princeton was the
the best fit for me both um you know
academically and for the best chance for
me to get on the field and fulfill my
dream of playing college football what
was the toughest school to call and say
you weren't going to come there toughest
coach
the yen to make that call to I there
wasn't really being on the toughest
school you know I reached out to all out
of respect I reached out to all the
coaches but your brother's at Arizona
State
did did Arizona State feel like all
right we got an in here and you got to
make that call and say uh coach I'm not
coming I think I think early on they
definitely thought they hadn't in
especially with the coaches that
recruited my brother there's on the
state but there's been plenty of
coaching changes that have happened
since my brother's been there and so
it's been it's been a little more
difficult to develop a relationship with
those coaches that you know come on the
staff you know a little more recently
and to kind of you know start the whole
process over with them so it's not like
who's known these coaches the whole time
so it wasn't you know a true heartbreak
when you know they got the news do you
see yourself as a football player or as
a student I see myself as a mix it as a
student-athlete that's the title that
they give us so that's the way I see it
and you got to be balanced you got to be
able to judge you know both your time
being being an athlete and it's it's
pretty much a full-time job once you get
to the you know Division one level and
you're playing in college and you got a
jug jug lawyers store I think Princeton
is definitely going to be a challenging
time for me and but I know I'm looking
forward to it and I chose it and I'm
happy don't you celebrate your birthday
on Tuesday definitely went out to dinner
with my family as my 18th birthday and
so I got the phone call in the morning
from Costa race you know informal read
on the admissions I was queer to go and
we just basically celebrated by the pool
out here in Cancun and then went and had
a big party party with all our family
and friends that are here and it's
pretty exciting and a big big stress you
know that's kind of lifted off my
shoulders and I'm I'm just happy to be a
tiger now do
you see the NFL is a possibility in your
future
yes the NFL is the ultimate goal you
know that's where I want to be but this
isn't the exact route to take why it's
it feels like it's a tougher route to
get to a position that's already tough
to play in the NFL you're absolutely
right and you know the IV's don't
produce as many NFL numbers or prospects
as SCC school or pack school or schools
than any other conferences but you know
I feel like the NFL is always going to
find the good players and the players
that you know have the work ethic and
can you know strive and make it to the
week so I still feel like if you don't
no matter what my decision was you know
I can I can do it and I just got to keep
true Who I am
and my work ethic and my attitude and
you know just my will to succeed and
also the NFL isn't you know live
decision average career life's a little
over three years maybe four for a
quarterback so you got to be prepared
kind of for you know the after after
football
you know life and if football doesn't
work out I'm going to be prepared with a
degree from Princeton to do you know
whatever it is I want to do and pursue
kind of that part of my life we have
somebody who works on our staff one of
the danites who went to Dartmouth and he
said you better be ready for some Ivy
League trash talk are you ready for that
brevin because I think it's a higher
higher level of trash talk than you
might be accustomed to they might be
using sophisticated words I'm not yet
familiar with but I'm sure I'm sure
ready for it okay way McLovin went to
Dartmouth McLovin is there something
you'd like to say to brevin who's now
going to Princeton no I mean I think
he's a brave kid to overlook the obvious
distasteful color of the uniform and the
fact that you can have real frat chip
what supper clubs what a dining clubs
and print oh wow wait wow it's begun
it's on this is on register get ready
for this I hope becomes the game in the
future so I can meet him in person and
whoa whoa
you know what we're going to be at the
we're going to the Yale game okay all
right we're going to that game
now which sideline racetrack what about
I want to be on the winning side line
I'll give you silent passes so you can
stand right next to coach duration no
wait wait that that might be an NCAA
violation there brother let's don't get
in trouble before you get there okay I I
guess you guys can choose that silence
whatever you guys think is whatever team
you guys think is gonna win all right
I'll leave you with this the best
quarterback and the family is me your
best you're better than your brother I
think we're both great and I love my
game I'm not on my game after and of
course you do
of course you do but I'm confident with
my ability I like that hey and see
thanks and congratulations to your
parents because they they did well here
so sometimes parents get kind of lost in
all these decisions there but make sure
you thank your parents for all they did
for you and good luck good luck with
this and we'll keep an eye on what goes
on at Princeton brevin thank you
thank you for having me on I appreciate
your time all right
that's brevin white the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience